now you might have had I'm going to say
it out loud Tobin you might have the
omnicron no I got tested for it yeah I
did too but you might not have the omnic
oh you're that guy I know people I know
people now who've had the omnicron
bearing really yeah but it's like real
quick and like it's more mild yeah super
mild right let's not shut the world down
no yeah I wish you know what I wish
they'd said about I'm pro-vaccine okay
no problem but I wish they'd said this
about the vaccine I wish they'd said
look take the vaccine take the booster
you're gonna it's not gonna stop you
from getting covered
but when you get it it'll make the
symptoms way less severe which is a fact
no they don't they didn't say that and
then they would act like you're a
student and you're immune and then a
booster is like well to be really
vaccinated you need boosters but you got
it but then Rogan had a doctor on a show
it's like we actually have hardcore
evidence where if you've had covered you
cannot get it again wow like it like
that's why herd immunity no one wants to
talk about it but people that like the
people getting sick or people that
didn't get it got vaccinated now they
have the whatever it's called variant
you know the Delta yeah Omicron yeah
like but we evidence the heavy evidence
shows Once people have had at the actual
covet the original strain they cannot
get it again wow so no one's getting it
twice well then I looked that up listen
according to this Doctor Who's pretty
smart well I looked it up the CDC said
um there's no conclusive proof yeah
there's been no evidence that people
have done it twice and but everybody
says you can get it three or four times
and everybody said uh my friend caught
it I know this doctor was saying it's
like chicken hugs once you get it you
can't get it again well not I don't know
and that might be misinformation I'm the
same from a high-level doctor that who's
on Rogan yeah so my friend my friend uh
had the booster well I've I've known
three people my mom my sister and my I
know some people who had the booster the
shots uh they got covered yeah and now
now once one of my friends got real sick
and the other one's fine the the other
the other people were I mean it was
tough but yeah just for two days but it
was this was their first time getting it
yes yes I do think for sure the vaccine
will make your symptoms way less strong
than they could be but just let's be
honest about it well yes we just need
that pill to come out yeah what is that
what is that what's supposed to be
supposed to be soon
yeah
you said uh oh yeah they say England
already has it or something England has
it they're doing those anti-whatever uh
pills in Florida I saw this black guy
just kind of a jack black guy and he's
and he's getting on plane and I swear to
God we're on Kansas City and he's just
got a mask and it's it's so mesh that I
can see his whole face I can see his
mouth
no no he's he's just sitting like that
and there he walks on and the flight is
him goes sir you have to have a
different mask he goes what because you
have to have masses I'm covering my
mouth is covered she goes so I can see
I called out it's like it's so hilarious
oh yeah